how many how many years did bad bar
bad what is it bad baby
bad baby train to do only fans and make
a million she's doing only fun yeah she
did on her 18th birthday she she's made
like 32 million yeah she made a million
on the first night yeah six million
so question how many years did she train
for that
it might have been a hidden skill
i mean my parents would be going to jail
if that was a hidden skill that she was
training for yeah yeah
but um no that's a fair point she
probably didn't have to train
for it but the fact of the matter is um
she saw the opportunity to make a
million in a day
and she took it now
the repercussions of it like he was
saying
people most people don't think about
that because we're living in a society
where we're so
uh we're so prone to well we're so drawn
to making fast money well they think the
money will keep coming
and that's what and that's what we're
seeing now with this because
um like this is from yahoo finance um
the uk economy shrinks in april as
households struggle against the cost of
like of living
um in the u.s um u.s weekly jobless
claims
uh housing hits 13 month low biden
another one biden under pressure as u.s
inflation hits 8.6 the highest in 40
years so there's recession coming yeah
and and that's why everyone i think
wants quick money because it's like
it's it's going up but like the jobs
like an engineer a nurse this and that
aren't going up so people are saying
like why am i studying three years for
something that i can't not really this
girl is making eighty six thousand
dollars a year that's what is she doing
nursing yeah the girl was a nurse she
quit yeah i missed right yeah yeah oh
yeah but that's that's still good money
in the u.s eighty-six thousand nurses
don't get that here
right but what i'm saying is it's people
with high paying skilled jobs that are
leaving that to do only fans yeah and
the problem is long term like what does
this do to them
well the thing is if the high school if
you would have got a high school already
and you only fans when the session comes
i'm going back to my high school job
who's going to hire you how are you
going to know why are you they're going
to do background shortly
did you say how are you going to know
everywhere how are you going to find me
you're on the internet there's there's
going to be yeah but my hand is
different to my real name and why are
you almost why subscribing to my channel
no no no but this is what you don't
understand like companies are going to
find ways to track faces
that's going to be a new industry is
finding people's [ __ ] online because
they don't want to hire people that are
a liability if we hire you and you're
like front facing towards customers your
liability yeah my parents like
fair enough i mean what i do doesn't
require me to be searched like that so
i've never thought yeah i didn't think
that was the point
but my handles look my handles are very
different to my name on paper so yeah
you know so yeah are you talking about
do you have an only fans
why you smelling it at home
but if you did like and then you said
you wanted to go into a regular job it
like everyone at your work could not
know but it takes two seconds for a
customer to walk in black i swear i
subscribe to you and then they tell
someone else and it becomes viral
a teacher got found out that way kids in
the primary school fans yeah yeah that's
what i saw but i think one thing that's
important to mention as well is that i'm
not i don't think we're saying here that
only fans is a bad job or this that
other what is telling people to
understand the repercussions of your
actions because a lot of people are too
fixated on the now if you don't focus on
the future that's where you fall into
silly mistakes what and i don't think
the government should have to pay for
you later if you're making six figures
in a month and now you're out of money
because you made poor choices like why
do i have to pay for that
like why is that my problem now and
that's what's going to happen with a lot
of these girls is they're not going to
get married because who's going to want
to marry you after only fans and then on
top of that
they're going to end up on the streets
because they spent all their money
because most people that get money quick
it goes quick is there a way to do on
your phones without showing your face
yeah of course yeah
yeah
so
does that is that the same thing then
you have to promote it you won't make
enough money if you're not showing face
trust me
[Laughter]
hey
that's a marketing genius
like you need to show your facebook you
want to draw
i have hobbies that i like to do in my
spare time okay
but yeah but no
if you if you don't show your face
you're making enough money you need to
show your face to make more money and if
you're a pretty girl you'll want to show
your face
see even that that says a lot the fact
that you have to show your face to make
the most money it it it it just proves
the point that they um i don't know the
founders of only fans or whatever they
know
how much is at risk so that's why
they're paying you more so what's your
no no they're not paying your
subscribers it's a subscriber
only fans was built as a platform for
artists to actually give behind the
scenes to their fans yeah so how did it
and then what happened was they didn't
put a cap on like adulterated content
and then
yeah people started using well
it could go away tomorrow i mean they
talked about last year they talked about
getting rid of it yeah yeah
and so you don't know how long it will
be
what is it just getting rid of only
friends or the whole like just only
found our things kevin samuels talked
about this um
rest in peace but like when when he was
still alive he talked about um
how
i can't remember how he phrased it but
basically it's going to be tough for
them to get investors to take it to the
next level and if they ever want to do
that they might have to get rid of the
x-rated content yeah and so then
overnight all of those girls could be
poof out of the job yeah and then what
it's like there's like influences though
it's like
influencing these kind of people oh is
that we want to attack we want to attack
like you know
sex workers on only fans because only
friends not just sex workers mentioned
that it's not just that but then if
you're an influencer or your podcaster
your youtuber like that tomorrow could
go away and then you have no some people
have no skill and they're doing these
they're doing these jobs like all these
passions or whatever and let's say
tomorrow you have less than subscribers
who how are you getting well but the
there's there's a difference though
because certain so i put it like with
with my podcast right it does i'll
always have a job because i know how to
run all the equipment i know how to run
multiple cameras like there's skills
i've had to take to get here there's
some influencers that come and go just
like that yeah but but it's about
building skills that'll last you a
lifetime
but the the issue that a lot of these
girls are going to have is this as quick
as the money came it's going to go
it's just the scary part and there's no
skill if they have no skill to go with
it it's a bubble i know i know you
you're arguing
no no i i agree with you yeah definitely
a bubble but i'm just saying that
there's a lot of other in especially now
now there's a lot of other jobs which
require no skill and get loads of money
but it's just like we always
see it in tech too a lot of tech
companies need to attack the only fan
skills maybe because this sex is easier
to go for them but i do feel like
there's so much other jobs as well in
this in this right now in this 2022
where if tomorrow comes a lot of people
are broke and not gonna have you know
right
especially women because women own
two-thirds of consumer debt even though
we make ten thousand dollars less than
men
i think that's why like well
it's because they're i feel like the
majority of people are used to women
earning less so now they've seen this
platform where like women earn more than
men like
i don't know the statistics but like a
lot of women earn probably a lot more
from only fans than men do and this is
the first platform where men are like
wait because everything else like you've
seen the pay gap everything like that
this is the one thing where they kind of
excel at and i think that's why
do you think
no it's not real is it no no no like
it's true in my industry 100 no there's
i've seen a lot of even actresses and
actors say like they've done the same
show same modeling modeling women make
more in the modeling industry if you
take into account so the thing is
they're not taking into account
personality traits so 60 of women have
never in their life asked for a raise
and they'll quit their job before they
ask for a raise if we're not choosing to
ask for a raise we can't be mad if we're
paid less yeah and we're picking
industries that we don't get paid as
much what about those sorry what about
those that do ask for a reason that
denied yeah
if they if they ask for a raise and
they're denied they probably don't have
the skills but it's not it's not because
you're a woman you have to remember you
take into account that as a business
owner you're not trying to you want to
grow your business and scale your
business so in a capitalist society you
pick the best to do the best job that
means man or woman so if you have a
woman in a job that asks for more money
she's good at her job the likelihood
he's going to give her that job i mean
give her the higher rates
what people what people fail to
understand is that there's
characteristics are involved so women
are actually more agreeable than men are
so men are so even if we're both
women are more agreeable than men so me
me and a woman can be doing the exact
same job i could be doing less of that
job but i demand more while she's happy
to accept that job of what it is so i'm
going to excel faster financially than
she will then there's other components
that risk may not men men work in high
risk jobs women tend to stay away from
the stem fields so that's science
men are the majority of workplace deaths
so if you're more if it's a more
dangerous job you're going to get paid
more
even they did a study on uber and uber
drivers make the same money this is how
you work but because men drive faster
they make more money than women if you
say they're more agreeable or do you
think that's just how
a lot of us just see women to be more
because you're more i feel like
personally i'm more nervous to ask i
don't have like just a mana question
than a woman i feel like it's more easy
i don't know like i i wouldn't more
appreciate yeah i wouldn't yeah like if
you're lost you're not going to more
time you're not going to go to a man if
you're lost for directions you'd usually
go to a woman it's it's agreeable yeah
trade agreeableness and it's like i
don't think they're naturally more
agreeable i think we are because
historically we had to raise children
like there's biological reasons the way
we feel the way we feel like when i went
around the room i asked them if they'd
wife a girl that did only fans the
reason they're saying no is because
historically they had to ensure
paternity and so it goes back to women
like we we pick up on things that men
don't see like every girl in here knows
that when you see a girl she gives you a
dirty look at the bar
and the men the men are like what what
what are you talking about it goes over
their head they don't pick up on small
social cues but we can and so women we
don't face rejection the way men do in
society so i think we're afraid of
rejection in the workplace that's why we
don't ask for raises
yeah and definitely i mean i've come
across that a lot and i've told my
friends you need to ask for more money
like women
and they're like oh i don't know i've
got enough skill and i've got
the same people in the same company
my my man friend is literally he's
demanding a higher higher paid money but
also higher position he doesn't he's not
warranted to have but because he's got
the balls for it
he gets it and they did the same job but
they're very different i do definitely
agree with that but i also find my
industry for example a lot more women
are in production and editorial which is
like the creative side of things like
that you get someone in production doing
a higher level job as a producer for
example was a pm
they don't get to say money well men
work more hours is the other thing and
maybe some do not always statistically
they do men work more hours yeah a lot
of hours so they must work in a lot of
hours yeah well i mean um you're you're
more of the exception you're not the
rule 100 percent no i think i'm sure and
i'm sure you you mentioned i'm not going
to say this on on live but your income
you make more than most men hmm
yeah so how can we say we're
discriminated against if you make more
than most men um
[Music]
that's a whole nother conversation do
you know what that is that's the victim
mentality and there's and there's quotas
specifically for women they're they they
seek out in engineering firms they're
begging women to come because there is
none right because we don't want to do
it we don't like hard jobs i don't know
would you guys would you guys if you got
paid half a million a year would you go
work on an oil rig
if you're passionate about it why not no
no no i'm saying i'm saying what would
you guys girls no i wouldn't yes yeah
but they might not have that interest i
know half of it no i don't want to see
oil yeah i wouldn't do it either without
you 100 yeah you would do it
uh
not really no it's not it's not
interesting
yes
but you see as i always shoot you too
sorry sorry i'm just here
oh yeah
no
no
i enjoy
it's a higher percentage of them are
willing to do it it's 50 versus 25. then
basing that off of
your income and how much you're going to
make or whatever like you enjoyed no
well no i'm basing it off of the fact
that men statistically pick harder jobs
like electricians plumbers if you look
if you make a list of the countries that
are the most egalitarian to the least
egalitarian um the pay gap increases it
doesn't decrease so the places where
women have more options to choose the
pay graph is increasing rather than do
you think it's because like more time at
least in the past women were even given
those opportunities so now that you've
given them something new it's more like
whoa i never had to like work this hard
working so it's it's unfamiliar whereas
like for a man like maybe their dad or
whatever is instructed into that son or
whatever you're going to be working a
hard working job whereas for the
daughter it's not that so then there's a
statement to make but that's why the
study done on egalitarian societies made
more sense because if you look at the
west where
women probably are reared to to be more
like women and or stereotypically women
and and men yeah need to be men it
wouldn't be a fair um analysis
so
so they looked at scandinavian countries
where they're the most equal so
you're meant to find that the more equal
society the more
alike men and women are supposed to
become but they find that the more equal
to society the more different men women
become so women tend to choose jobs that
involve people whilst men choose to to
do jobs that involve things so women's
going to stuff like hr nursing teaching
whilst men going to the stem fields and
you're going to make a lot of money
instead a lot more money in the stem
fields
in comparison to
jobs in the public sector
i guess yeah
um okay so